بعد اسبوع من الاحداث التي شهدتها بلده
حوار جنوبيه نابلس بدات الحركه تعود
للبلده بشكل تدريجي
مئات المحل التجاريه فتحت ابوابها ودبت
الحركه في شارعها الرئيسي وسط تعزيزات
امنيه الاسرائيليه بلشنا الصبحيات طبعا
انت شايف
والجميع شايف انتشار الجيش بشكل مش طبيعي
على امتداد الشارع الرئيسي وحتى داخل
البلد
بنتامل انه الحياه تعود شوي شوي تعود
لطبيعتها اثارهم ارتكبه المستوطنون هنا ما
زالت باقيه سلطان ابو سريس يحاول لملمه
بقايا ما تكبده من خسائر يقدرها بمئات
الاف الدولارات يقول ان الاغلاق الذي
فرضته قوات الاحتلال فاقم من خسائره
الف دولار هون
والمحل تقريبا كل يوم بتسكر قاعد بخسر من
الف ل 1200 دولار
ويعني دمار دمار يعني انا من هنا لست سبع
شهور اذا ما برد برجع من هون بخسر هاي
الارض تقريبا
اجارها سنه من 30 الى 35 الف دولار
ما تعرضت له بلده حواره والقرى المحيطه
بها دانته لجنه المتابعه العليا للجماهير
العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر خلال جولتها
الميدانيه في البلده نحن الان هنا لنكون
نقف على الاحداث مباشره نوصل صوتنا الى
اهلنا انهم ليسوا وحدهم ولا يمكن ان يكون
وحدهم وايضا نحن اطلقنا حمله جمع تبرعات
من اجل المساهمه في اعمار ما افسده
المجرمون
قوات الاحتلال ابقت على اجراءاتها
العسكريه المشدده في البلده بناء على
تعليمات وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بهدف
تامين طرق المستوطنين واحباط اي هجمات
محتمله ضدهم
فتحت المحال من جديد في بلده حواره بعد
اجراءات عسكريه اسرائيليه واعمال تخريبيه
من قبل المستوطنين لكن كثيرا من
الفلسطينيين هنا يقولون ان تحقيق الهدوء
يبقى مرهونا بوقف الاعتداءات عليهم
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن تلك الاعمال سمير
ابو شمالي الجزيره من بلده حوار الجنوبيه
نابلس فلسطين